[Musique]
on ne comprend pas pourquoi les
professionnels de santé notamment les
kings thérapeute mais tous les
professionnels de santé en libéral on
exprime de grandes difficultés pour
accéder à des dotations cohérente un des
dotations qui leur permettent de
travailler alors qu'à côté des millions
de masques vont être mis en vente par la
grande distribution et notamment
notamment des masques dits chirurgicaux
tpo ça a l'air beaucoup plus facile que
pour les services de l'état et c'est en
ce sens qu'on est amer voire un peu
écoeuré quand même parce que c'est quand
même notre vie qui est en quête dans la
balance comme ce n'est pas un procès
vis-à-vis de la grande distribution mais
c'est une incompréhension et nous
appelons les pouvoirs publics et à
l'état à être conne et cohérent entre
ses dires et ses actes faut-il rappeler
que pour les seuls médecins 25 médecins
au moins sont décédés d'une infection
d'une contamination aux bobines et que
des dizaines d'entre eux sont encore en
réanimation avec hélas un pronostic
réservé on a obtenu une dotation d'état
de la direction générale de la santé qui
correspond à 6 masques par
kinésithérapeute libéral par semaine
dont 2 ffp2 le fameux masque qui protège
le mieux
le professionnel de santé alors que les
kinésithérapeutes interviennent auprès
de patients pour faire notamment des
séances de kinésithérapie respiratoire
au cours desquelles les patients tous
voir crash bien évidemment postillonne
donc notre clé de voûte ce sont des
objectifs de santé publique et tant pour
la population que pour une juste
protection de s'élever ceux qui tous les
soirs sont applaudis à 20h et qui
méritent que la nation leur offre des
garanties de protection ou exercer au
mieux ses missions de soins dans ce
contexte aussi difficile